welcome to this video playing giant Nick
giant Nick Nikolai popping in okay very
really so many masters around never
heard of this guy ok let's see a double
of fianchetto against the Kings Indian
yeah this is a very popular way you for
black to play with this night recapture
however it is in fact quite a
comfortable position for why'd ya both
recaptures now are good I always liked
the pawn recapture let's let's do this
getting in air for ya ok 95 is not a big
problem I just play a form in fact the
Queen f6 is just a bad move because I'm
getting in what no way this night is
totally unsupported you cannot play
Bishop f5 ok so let's let's review this
so g four wins apiece yea or not hmm
who is this not winning a piece I don't
get it okay I mean 95 is also just
strong but let's just should just win
apiece black forfeits due to this
connection yeah the poor man's way of
resigning strikes yet again he dashed
our this stuff in 20 seconds and then
was lost but quite sure why yeah I mean
it this whole line is not not
particularly great but Queen f6 is just
just not helping at all I mean if you
just think about it for for 10 seconds
or five seconds you will recognize
that's just bad because I play 93 I will
play 95 later of course not blundering
the Queen moving it first you're just
getting in a couple of Tempe f4 as a
temple and here 193 is yeah on the icing
on the cake it's make no sense at all
can you should go back probably and then
I will play I'm not quite sure in which
order rookie one Ruby 122 and this this
move coming and here you just lose this
time with the Queen Queen tr6 is just
just terrible so while this is what he
did and now of course the abisha f5
blunders the piece to g4 you should just
go back here of course if you look at
this position this is yeah I can do
before and I a queen here yeah something
like that is just just not going to end
well but it just played too many
mistakes i mean this this whole line is
not good and queen f6 is just very very
bad okay quickly cook game but i won't i
wanted to point out the the rigid moves
that he played but i really don't
understand why you would play all this
so quickly I mean really Queen f6 is so
obviously bad
you can only play it yeah like in review
play in a second yeah Queen f6 but why
not five seconds and you recognize that
this is bad so I really don't understand
sometimes okay well thanks for watching